[Music]
it's up to us
no it's hunting donny why danny
because that's what she fears come on
help me one two three
take danny to a safe place and i'll take
care of this bear
[Music]
what are you going to do i'm going to
play with it
get the wrath up here
are you crazy that thing will kill you
he's right it's matching
so amir no italy
what's the last thing you remember danny
he said we had to run
the reason you survived is because
you're a very
uncommon girl
you're not alone not anymore
do you know what mutants are
would anyone like to share their first
time rain
i was 13 i thought it was a dream
i just lost control sam
i started panicking people got hurt
roberto my girlfriend a partner
diliana i killed 18 men one
by one
[Music]
this isn't a hospital it's a cage
it's important we find out your power so
we can help you get better
i saw something
i don't think she wanted me to see
[Music]
[Applause]
i don't think we're here to get better
this place takes your greatest fear it
makes you live through it
until it kills you
he's there
we can get out of this together
[Music]
you